there's a lot to think about when
starting a company and it can often feel
overwhelming we talked to successful
founders about the traits needed to
build a startup let's hear from them now
now I tend to be very aggressive in
terms like when I want to you know get
things done I'll get them done also tend
to be impatient in a way so it's like
hard as being impatient it's hard on me
right but sometimes it just like helps
me ink it you get stuff done in terms of
cow shake and I like we get along very
well that we were both that way and we
we get the god-like gratification from
seeing or building stuff in our hand
it's getting getting natural product
yeah and seeing that and giving it to
users mm-hmm it's amazing feeling to
just be able to like you draw these
wireframes and then a week later you see
it like it live in the app store so
what's a skill that you feel like
entrepreneurs must have before they
start building a company our product not
sure if it's a skill that they must have
but it's like something that I've
learned over time yeah that really helps
me understand better about what startups
that are like and how to operate them is
that when I first began we thought that
failure is everything like this one idea
that I have needs to be executed
perfectly and it needs to succeed
otherwise a failure so at one point when
we were like you know like doing this
paper swipe at model and we're getting
analyze users I think I had this idea
that if we switch or if you pivot then
it's a failure and I and I have failed
and it was very hard to accept but if
you think about it in a different way
we're like you you're doing
experimentation it's like a like a
scientific like science project
where you're trying to validate some of
the assumptions that you have given the
some of the resources you have they need
to think about it that way
it was a great experimentation where we
realized that like even though we you
know tried all these things it did not
work so must be the idea and not the
execution
so I would so these days what we do is
that like if you haven't
yeah or if you have a goal we would come
up with some of these experimentation
like experiment 1 2 3 and we'll try them
out and see you know really track the
metrics to make the judgment call on
like instead of taking it as like oh
it's my idea and my dream I need to make
it happen if you consider it as like hey
these are some of the ideas that we'll
try if they fail that's okay we'll move
on at the end of the day like the worst
thing that can happen to us is that we
fail and we don't know exactly why we
failed was it the idea or was it our
execution knowing exactly why I failed
would be it's like one of the learning
that will help us go to the next one
yeah so so failure is an option but you
need to know why right exactly
and you have to like it's best if you
fail quickly yeah the worst thing is to
fail slowly and painfully over like
yours so it's just like a band-aid like
rip it off and get it done yeah